clearly
today and the overall effort that julie
is now leading is very very complex
but one with tremendous potential for
leveraging
the the capacities we have here on
campus
to
demonstrate
uh what can be done in terms of the
campus operations of course but also in
terms of the broader impact
from the research that supports some of
that work and from the broader
information and
guidance that we can provide and that
that's a core part of the of the mit
mission
so this morning um i think to kick our
to kick the day off um we have a panel
that's going to help uh provide some of
that context for the rest of the day
and
framing effectively for uh for the
discussion
and so with me i have uh professor henry
jacoby jake as i get to refer to him
who is um
one of our eminent uh eminent experts in
in the in the climate change arena
and jake i think is going to be able to
provide us with some context with regard
to the bigger picture which is driving
all of this and how that relates to mit
and to the sustainability effort jeremy
poindexter a graduate student in the
department of material
science and engineering is going to
provide one of the i think the key
elements which is a demonstration what
the students are doing what they can do
john charles who's our vice president
for is t he's going to speak about what
asmt is that core element of the
institute what they can bring to bear
and then um been a i think a trauma who
is the newly minted director of global
initiatives at the broad institute and a
former senior advisor on climate change
innovation in the obama administration
we'll be able to provide some context i
think for the broader effort and how
that all comes together so with that i
think i'll open it up to some remarks on
the panel and and afterwards we'll have
some moderate discussion
okay
well thank you and i thanks to julie for
for giving me a chance to to talk to
this to talk to this group
uh
sustainability is one of the odd words
it seems to communicate with everybody
but no one knows how to define it
uh and there are many issues at issue
today but i i'll i'm gonna just talk
about one one issue where it's not hard
to say what the problem is of
sustainability and that is about about
what's going on on the climate and what
it may mean
for the institute
but for purposes of this conversation
i'm just going to stipulate
about the climate we can have a
discussion later if you want but the
climate is changing it's changing in
ways events changes and and things we
can observe that are consistent with
what the what the models say is what we
can expect in the longer term and
greater
in greater magnitude
and the thing you have to remember think
i always remember when you're shoveling
snow you have to the mantra you say is
there's a difference between
climate and weather
so don't don't be don't be don't be
misled
it is it is happening and the other
thing is
the second thing is that the project the
projections of what of of of the future
indicate that the risk is really very
very great
and and i will say that what's going on
in the international system as the
negotiations take place leading to a
major event again in paris of the
framework convention is not optimistic
about taking the measures that would be
necessary to avoid
or to substantially reduce this risk
maybe more things will come later but
but but right now the the projections of
this risk are
are are very great
and the third thing it's it's a
substantial risk to this to society to
societies and the environment
you didn't give me an hour and a half to
do this i'll just stipulate
that that's true and mit is doing a lot
in this area i mean we don't talk about
that here but across the campus there
are hundreds of people working on this
issue
ranging from
the psychology about how we think about
this to the economics and policy
analysis what we might do about it to to
work on uh on existing and potential new
technologies so there's a lot of going
on here
but the issue here is the campus that
the room today the issue is the campus
and that's and
when you ask me to do this the question
is why
why
why this is a gl this is a global issue
um
uh the united states is roughly one
quarter of the greenhouse gas emissions
massachusetts is a little bit more than
two percent of the united states and mit
is a little piece of massachusetts why
would you worry about why would why
would you pay any attention uh to to
mit's contribution and if you think
about climate changing well i work in an
air-conditioned office i don't have a
big problem uh is that is that a serious
issue for for us at all i mean probably
you know it's far off in the future why
why do we worry about this why is this
an issue for the for a discussion of the
campus and i'll just make two i'll just
talk talk about two aspects of this the
two aspects about it
one is the issue of what we might do
about mitigation of greenhouse gases and
the other is
are we are we really vulnerable here
does it make does it really make make
any difference
so
as to why we might be concerned about
greenhouse gases i think it's always
good to be good
i mean why not be moral you know it's
okay
you need we need to stick up we need to
stay up with what the city wants us to
do what the state's doing and if we can
do things that are useful
that seems like a good thing to do but
there are other reasons i think
that
lead
to a focus on on the institute
taking more attention to to the
greenhouse gas emissions
when when our effect on the global
problem is really insignificant
and there are three parts to it and it's
my it's my kind of productive triangle
about mit that is is innovation
demonstration and teaching
i mean what we do what we do here is
kind of our our self self
image of this is is that we are we
innovate we are an analysis driven
innovative culture
so we'll you'll talk about we talk about
innovation juliary talks about
innovation
we do that that's what we that's our
that that's our kind of mission in life
but one thing another thing is different
about mit and a contribution to this is
that we are analysis driven
and we could tell i'm sure julie could
tell stories about things that other
institutions like us run out and do
things without thinking very seriously
about what they're doing
can they meet the tasks then they meet
the targets they pick are the measures
they're taking really significant in
terms of influencing the problem and the
like
so
mit is a kind of
innovative analysis-driven culture is an
important part of this
and the second part of that is then
demonstration
we are
visible
globally for reasons that none of us
created we have inherited we we inherit
at mit
of visibility globally for what we do
which which which which is it is our
inheritance we didn't create this uh
and and so it is it's uh an important
aspect of what we do
can be communicated more in terms of in
terms of what
what the effect is on others and of
course we teach
and we teach our students we teach our
and and the teaching involves the
students and the staff and the faculty
and the alumni
and and and not only the people who we
teach in the classroom but a lot of the
people we've had here at staff and
students and faculty are now running
this show in in in the states in
washington so that that impact is
is much bigger and i think worth paying
a lot more of attention a lot more of
attention to than you would expect from
an insignificant effect on the emissions
themselves
are we now natural are we now a natural
leader
i don't know i'm not aware of that but
certainly the opportunity certainly the
opportunity is there for that reason
the second point i would make is about
about
adaptation and resiliency mit is
vulnerable
i do work on on severe storms sea level
rise and severe storms
and looking at looking at the
projections of of of sea level rise the
risk of sea level rise and what may
happen in terms of the more intense or
intense storms particularly
tropical storms like hurricanes but also
the nor'easters also have have a
phenomena have an effect can have an
effect or becoming more severe predicted
to become more severe and we're sitting
here protected by the by the charles
river dam
and other parts of cambridge by the by
the dam in in uh in medford the risk was
always there that we could have been
flooded if we'd had so if we had if we
had sandy a hundred miles 100 kilometers
100 miles farther north we would have
had that problem here
but you know we were lucky
but that risk is going that risk is is
is going up
and and and so this campus is those of
you who walk around the tunnels know how
much of this campus
you know at high tide the basin is is
below sea level
so and a lot of this campus is below sea
level now
so
and and and it's not so so so the risk
that risk is going up and i think it's
something we're going to have to take
very seriously here and it's only one of
the effects of climate change but that's
the one that i think is most
significant and the other point i'll
make is that
the sustainability of mit as an
institution is
totally dependent on the sustainability
of the community we're sitting in
the city of cambridge the city of boston
we the so that the the the um
that sustainability sustainability of
this as an institution depends on things
like the fundamental infrastructure of
the city
so think about the possibility of storm
damage to
water and sewage
fresh pond for example those who drink
fresh pond
transportation systems we've had that
experience
the electric power to run the whole
system so we are dependent on those we
are depending on those systems you're
going to hear more about that later in
this session and it is true that that
people at mit you those many of you here
in the room are actually engaged with
this work that's going on in cambridge
and boston but mit has a i think a
contribution to making that beyond its
own
begun to our own
facilities the vulnerability of our own
facilities you know i haven't gone
around to ask how many of the emergency
generators are in the basement for
example kind of a quick did we put your
generators in the basement in the
national building yeah okay
so
but but one of the issues here is not
just to be aware of those problems but
to do but to do the right analysis of
those problems so one of the things that
where we have a contribution to make i
think both by the staff members here who
engaged in
with the city's uh work and the work of
the of the of the uh
various faculty you're engaged in doing
research on these on on these questions
is is doing this right this is a
complicated question of how you adapt
investment in infrastructure to it to an
uncertain risk that's rising over time
it's our kind of problem and one where
we have uh we have a real contribution a
real contribution to make so climate
change is not really the topic only
topic for today but i i would say that
that uh
i love the title you pick game game
changing no make choose no small goals
you say we want to be game changers
i don't know if we can be a game changer
i would just tell you that this is a
this is a game that we need to be in not
only for ourselves but for the but to
help support the communities because
when you think about the campus you
shouldn't think about the campus as sort
of drawn by the boundary that we put up
here the campus is really the city
because we don't survive we don't
sustain
unless the city unless the city that
we're in
sustains as well and we have a
contribution
to make there and then i'll make one
just add one plug there is the the
the the uh
climate conservation comm conversation
committee is running it's running a
number of
of events to try to draw
uh input from the community both to
inform and and draw input from the
community about various issues on the
climate on mit's response to climate and
one of these one of those is precisely
on the topic today's session
uh on on on what what we're doing with
the with the uh with the infrastructure
of the of the campus itself and how we
manage it how we run it what we should
do about it and such
so there is a session which i encourage
you to attend and i've forgotten the
date sarah
the 12th of march so look for that and
come and and and and
build on what goes on today and and
bring that to that to that more public
discussion where we're trying to involve
not just the people who help run mit who
are sitting in this room but a lot of
the students and other people who who
are our clients thank you
thank you very much for uh for having me
indeed it's an honor to be in this group
it's an honor to be up here on the stage
um so from my perspective i'll try to
bring us in to the campus itself uh
indeed there are a number of things we
can do on our campus to serve to try to
figure out can we develop the best
practices and be able to enable others
to recognize these are the opportunities
you should be able to apply
we have per square foot one of the most
energy-intensive campuses in the world
and it comes from the fact that
we don't have liberal arts quite as
prominently as most other universities
do as a result we have
less lecture rooms and more laboratory
rooms
and as a result of that we have a lot of
equipment that we need to run in all our
facilities we also very densely packed
right so our campus is incredibly
engineered
to accommodate our ability to go ahead
and develop the next set of technologies
but as we look at that we have grown the
campus indeed one building at a time
and the question once in a while
comes forward to say well there are some
projects that indeed will unify many
many of us
one example is mit nano that is being
constructed right now you probably
started seeing construction roughly
speaking in june last year and it's
going to keep on going till about
spring 2018
and in the constructing of the structure
the right question to ask is
can we go ahead and show the best
paradigm we can imagine uh in what it
means to develop a facility that will be
used by about 2 000 individuals in the
course of a year to get you a scale of
2000 individuals we have about 6 600
graduate students uh four thousand four
hundred undergrads and one thousand four
hundred post docs
so look at the post docs and grad
students together that's about eight
thousand individuals about a quarter of
them will step in this building in a
course of a year
that's an estimate but and probably an
underestimate to how useful this
building will be which really means we
have an incredible way to affect the
quality of research of that those people
in the same time responsibility
to provide our campus the best practice
in actually developing a structure like
it this is a view of mit nano from the
infinite corridor that you'll be able to
step in this new courtyard behind it
here is the cross section of it it's uh
entirely laboratories it has no offices
not for students not for faculty few
offices for staff who actually operate
the facility itself
but this building is extremely
intensively laboratory space
as much of the fact that imaging subfab
space down on a in a basement that's a
quietest place actually and probably the
least energy intensive one the place
that you have instruments that need an
extremely small vibration a small amount
of electromagnetic noise places that you
can move atoms around and image them
without worrying about them getting out
of your sight and then you step into the
clean rooms and those clean rooms those
clean rooms are two stories tall each
one of them there are two of them
every one of them because one whole
floor above the clean room is dedicated
to fan deck
to place that actually moves the air
around
a tremendous amount of air needs to be
moved which means a tremendous amount of
energy needs to be expanded in order to
operate a space like this so what are
the best practices that we can apply
well probably many as a matter of fact
if you look at that movement of air is
there a way to generate to to design the
filters to make the path of least
resistance available and yet provide the
quality of the air that we need to
operate the facility like this how good
of an air do we need actually we need a
very good air
if you have asthma or any other airborne
disease step into the clean room and
you'll clarify it easily because there
should be no dust particles floating
around at least this very small amount
why because the scale that we are
working at in mit nano is nanoscale
nanoscale well dust particles about 1000
nanometers in size or bigger so a dust
particle is bigger than devices we'll be
playing with we can't have dust well how
do you actually purify it well what one
way to do it is to either pass your air
through a filter that's small or through
a filter that's big what's the benefit
well if you go ahead and have a very big
filter very thick filter and allow
provide a lot of space for the filtering
you might be able to actually slow down
your air not have it go quite as often
well actually you have to have it go
quite a bit through the filter but the
pressure per unit per square well a
force per square per square area
can be reduced and consequently the
driving force to drive through a filter
can be reduced
allowing to have more efficient systems
being able to design the space and get a
trade-off of space in this case versus
energy was something that we considered
so looking at clean room it's a high
energy use space there are variety of
typical designs for typical spaces so
and a typical office goes through about
one air exchange per hour
that's a c
h
the uh if you look at the conference
room it's about two air exchanges per
hour laboratory anywhere from four to
twelve conference rooms um uh indeed i
said about two animal vivarium about 15
and then comes clean room
about 250 to 500 air exchanges per hour
uh you need to have that many air
exchanges to get rid of those dust
particles do you need to have that many
air exchanges at night
well depends depends on when the users
are there because actually the only
source of dust
inside the clean room well the primary
source of dust are the users
that users especially if they haven't
showered
yeah you actually shed skin cells and if
you haven't gotten yourself rid of those
skin cells ahead of time that's a bit of
a problem stepping into the clean room
well what if i can monitor the use of
the clean room find out how many users
there are find out
if there is a significant amount of
commotion in the room itself by
monitoring both presence of individuals
as well as monitoring the quality of air
i should be able to maybe slow down my
air exchanges indeed why do it why keep
passing the air through the filters if
the air is clean enough so variable
control of the air filtration is one of
the rules we're going to be using
utilizing inside the building and we can
see we should be able to dramatically
reduce the operation to about 100 air
exchanges per hour and even this we
think will be an over need for what is
truly needed
now that being said uh we have looked
variety of other things building like
this exhausts a lot of air a lot of
poison there right air that needs to be
scrubbed out before being pushed out but
air that has been warmed up because you
used it inside that place
on a day like today right you the air
we're gonna be putting out would be on
these 65 70 degrees
uh outside is about 20 or 30. can you
recover some of that heat before
expelling it outside the building yes
you can and being able to actually
utilize that air recovery heat air
recovery would be significant again
other energy saving
there are indeed over a hundred
different sustainability options we
considered in the course of about nine
months
on what could be done for
providing a better operation of mit nano
better in the form of more sustainable
operation of mit nano
so we have looked at trade-offs we have
looked at the first costs
versus operational cost savings as time
progresses if i can slow down my fans i
can save a lot of energy i can also save
a lot of cost
i might have to have initial investment
in my infrastructure that maybe exceeds
what the cheapest way of building the
building is but fairly quickly i'll
recover the cost
just from a point of view even of
economy economic arguments you can say
energy savings is a very valuable thing
to do in the long run and so looking at
over 100 sustainability options we
adopted about 60. every one of them in
detail being able to provide us a clear
metric on these are the amount of time
that we'll be able to very quickly
recover the initial cost excess cost
will have to incur and then from there
on have initial energy saving excessive
energy savings
after that
point of payback
indeed
opportunities for utilizing our campus
in the form of mit nano or in the form
of any new structure we choose to build
is incredible we have a very old campus
about to
celebrate its 100th anniversary right in
just a couple of years
here next year
that being said there are tremendous
number opportunities to look through the
campus and recognize these are the
opportunities for improving it or call
it these are opportunities for testing
our best practice
utilizing our campus as a laboratory as
a place that will allow us to learn the
best practice and then be able to
publicize so that others can go ahead
and adapt whatever we have learned
i'll stop there and thank you for your
attention
so good morning everyone um it's truly a
pleasure for me to be here i'm really
excited to have so many great minds in
one room to discuss ways that we can
synthesize efforts to strengthen campus
sustainability
ostensibly i am here to discuss with you
today
work that i have helped
accomplish through a class project so
just to give you some context i'm a
second year phd student in the
department of mechanical engineering and
last semester i took a class called
fundamentals of photovoltaics and so
these four students and i delphine isaac
conrad and emily sought to answer one
question which is how much solar power
could mit generate we wanted to
investigate the potential for installing
photovoltaic solar panels here on campus
and so when the five of us met with
steve lenoux and sarah verlinski at the
office of sustainability we were a bit
surprised to learn that this isn't
something that it seemed like mit had
seriously considered before having very
large scale systems
now there are some systems on campus as
you can see here there are five of them
and we were actually able to tour these
systems as part of this class
but these systems are are relatively
small in size they're less than a
hundred kilowatts capacity and so
they provide at any point in time less
than half a percent of
total power to mit
and additionally
um
these systems are relatively hidden not
very many people on campus know about
them i don't think i certainly didn't
when we started this project
and so when we started this project i i
sort of thought about why that was you
know mit
is
a place where we are masters of science
and engineering and technology and it
seemed to me that installing solar
panels on roofs would be sort of an easy
obvious way of making campus more
sustainable
but as we progressed with this project
i started to understand a bit more that
projects like these which are very large
scale
um are difficult and you can encounter
barriers
as a material scientist i really like
understanding what fundamentally governs
behavior and so instead of just saying
that oh these are these barriers that we
need to overcome i want to i want to
focus on this i want to understand what
are these barriers
what do they look like
and i think they come in in three main
categories
the first kind of barriers are technical
in nature so efforts in sustainability
require synthesizing knowledge from all
kinds of different fields not only
science and engineering but economics
and policy and psychology among many
others
and
understanding the relationships between
inputs like materials money social
behavior and outputs like carbon
emissions can be really really complex
and those relationships can be uncertain
additionally there are logistical
barriers we at mit are comprised of many
different departments with our own
corners of expertise
and mit is decentralized sometimes it
can be a little bit difficult to
organize
people to come together and doing that
is sometimes chaotic and time consuming
and complicated
and lastly there are social barriers
at mit we are students we are faculty
staff
administrators and alumni and sometimes
we have different viewpoints and we are
motivated motivated by different things
i know we students sometimes can be a
little bit impatient and strong-headed
occasionally but
i think it's important to recognize that
those kinds of differences are really
motivated for the sheer amount of on
respect that we have for this great
institution
so i think that at the end of the day
working on sustainability is hard
because
you encounter barriers in all three of
these areas
luckily there are ways to overcome these
barriers
and this is something that we were able
to do with this class project so
before telling you how to overcome them
i'd like to just show you
so with this class project we wanted to
know how much solar power mit could
generate
and so
during the class
our professor tony bonacici introduced
us this to this amazing tool called
matchwell which is an online rooftop
solar mapping tool
it uses lidar data in
along with satellite imagery in order to
assess the potential for performance for
photovoltaic systems on roof
all throughout cambridge
it turns out that this tool was
developed in part by a faculty here a
faculty member here at mit in the
school of architecture christophe
reinhart
and so this tool was really useful in
allowing us to assess to answer this
question
we calculated through natural that there
is around 57 football fields
of area on campus
and so
about half of that is usable for
photovoltaic systems due to things like
shading on some roofs and ventilation
equipment i'm sure there will be lots of
ventilation equipment on top of mit nano
for example
um and so with a 16 solar pane of 16
efficient solar panel
it turns out that you could install
around 27.5 megawatts of capacity for
solar which is significant when compared
to
the peak power demand at mit of around
25 to 30 megawatts
so this seemed really promising so what
we wanted to do in this project is go
more in in more detail and look at
specific places on campus where we could
do this
so through maps what we were able to do
is design sort of simulated pv systems
this image on the right shows um
some systems i'm not sure if you can see
there's but there's small circles here
which represent an individual panel and
we are able to extract statistics
corresponding to how much power those
systems could create and how large they
would be in area and how much they would
cost
but since we know that sometimes
simulations only tell you so much
sometimes you need to uh you know apply
real-life constraints so we actually
went up and visited some of these
buildings
so this is the a picture of the zesker
center which is one of my favorite
buildings on campus for pv it's
beautiful it is wide open it's flat
there's not very much else on the roof
it gets sunlight at all hours of the day
so there are a few buildings like this
which i think are very promising
there were some other buildings that
seemed initially very promising as well
but yielded some surprises so the top of
the library annex building here
is also flat and open
but it has this interesting pebble roof
structure which i don't think many
people knew was there including the
people who worked in that building and
so
um
this was this taught us that sometimes
you actually do just have to go and
visit the location
there are some buildings on campus that
surprised us that seemed more promising
than we initially thought including the
building we're in right now um despite
the media lab's multi-tiered roof
structure there are some wide open flat
sunlit areas so
maybe in a couple years at this
conference this presentation will be
powered by the sun that would be cool
and lastly there are a few buildings on
campus that sort of didn't really
surprise us at how poor they were for
photovoltaics and without
pointing them out and naming names i'm
sure you can think of what buildings i'm
talking about
so at the end of the day we assess that
buildings buildings like the first three
that i mentioned
um
could have the potential of providing up
to four megawatts of solar capacity at
any given time um and these are
buildings that we could essentially
install solar systems on immediately
without really
the need for some serious retrofit work
um and so we're really excited about
this we pitched this idea to president
reif and deputy
executive vice president tony sharon
and we're really looking forward to
working with them and taking this
project outside of the classroom
so to come back to this how are we able
to overcome these barriers in this
specific project
well on the technical side
we had the knowledge um through this map
dwell tool of all of our constraints
it provided us with really valuable data
that allowed us to go very far in our
analysis and we had the problem-solving
framework through what we learned in
lectures to be able to apply those
constraints properly
on the logistical side
steve and sarah at the office of
sustainability were really great
resources for us and able to provide us
with information we wouldn't have
otherwise had access to and give us some
insight about how
it would be
how we could implement this kind of
thing at mit with other departments
and as i mentioned administrators have
been really receptive to this idea
and really that's sort of why i'm
standing here right now today
and lastly
it's the common values that all of us in
this room share
really caring about sustainability that
made this project possible in the first
place
and so the students administrators
faculty and staff
really are passionate about this work
and that is a huge part of what made
this possible now what about this last
thing momentum
we know that from physics momentum is a
force applied over time right
and sometimes forces can be external in
nature perhaps all of us are sitting in
this room today because we read the mit
mission statement which says that we
seek to develop and each member of the
mit community the ability and passion to
work wisely creatively and effectively
for the betterment of humankind that's a
very noble sentiment and i think that
that sentiment is reflected in a lot of
the work that we do here at mit
but as i've learned as a material
scientist i think that the strongest
forces in nature are often internal so
what i challenge you all to do today is
to really think about deeply why you're
here in this seat what brought you here
today what motivates you and to share
that share that with your colleagues
sitting next to you here and share that
with the people that aren't in this room
because that is what we need in order to
build on this momentum and we're
fortunate that momentum has already been
building there are thousands of students
faculty staff and alumni at this
institute calling for the institute to
take stronger leadership in climate
change for example by divesting the
endowment from fossil fuels there is as
has been mentioned this mit climate
change conversation going on where we
can discuss ways to increase
sustainability including installing
solar panels on roofs and so
i think that if we can tap into that
then we really have the ability to
overcome these barriers because here at
mit we're some of the best problem
solvers in the world we have a
wide array of resources that we have
access to and so if we can really build
on the momentum that we have already
helped establish that's already going on
i see really great things for us ahead
so with that i look forward to
working on sustainability and talking
about more specific ways to synthesize
efforts to strengthen campus
sustainability thank you
well thank you julie for inviting me to
be a part of this this very special
event and you know i'm excited to be
here this morning you know as all of you
probably realize we live in two worlds
today we live in the uh you know the
biosphere and we also live in the uh
tetanosphere and in the uh in the
biosphere
you know it's comprised of a complex uh
you know web of nodes uh these
ecosystems and something bad happens
somewhere within the uh the biosphere
other components just uh kick in and
naturally
you know
restore balance you know to that
ecosystem over the next few minutes what
i plan to do is talk to you about why i
believe the interconnected roles of big
data and the internet of things
can help us
create within the technosphere the
characteristics that start to mimic
the uh biosphere in ways that could end
up being a key to how we can scale
sustainable living you know big data
sometimes referred to as the digital
exhaust of our digital world but it's
actually can be a thought of as a new
natural resource
you know big data with its ability to
provide the the high speed analysis and
large uh you know volumes of data and
varieties of data
they can help deliver a real-time
situational awareness that wasn't
possible for us in the in the techno
sphere
not too long ago
and the internet of things with its
ability to interconnect devices you know
smart devices and deliver this web of
node so together when you put these
uh put put these characteristics uh
together in a synergistic way they have
the ability for relaying information
and for uh forming a responsive system
these are some of the essential
characteristics
of uh what we would need to be able to
mimic the biosphere within the uh within
the technosphere and restore balance
when uh when bad things happen so
consider the uh potential implications
for uh sustainable
living you know currently those of us
that live sustainably do so out of
choice
you know we decide and we make a
conscious decision that we're going to
alter our behavior
okay and some things are uh set and
forget
you know it's uh like installing solar
panels you know you've done it you
kind of forget changing out your light
bulbs to led you know bulbs kind of a
set and forget things but when it comes
to ongoing behavior things get a little
bit messier you know we we forget
uh to unplug our chargers you know we uh
we get lazy
uh because there's extra things because
we you know we're choosing to alter our
behavior
and living sustainably
so furthermore
i would argue that no amount of
campaigning
is ever going to significantly change
this kind of
convenience driven majority behavior
that all of us uh kind of default back
into people naturally tend to use the
things and precisely the way they were
designed and unfortunately a lot of
things were not designed with energy
conservation you know in mind
so now imagine if all the things that we
currently associate with sustainable
living could be automated
in ways that we didn't have really have
to think about them you know our lights
would only come on when we come near
them they would come on to the
brightness that was necessary for
whatever activity we were engaged in you
know our devices would only charge
themselves when the when the energy was
the cheapest
you know uh our gardens even you know
would only uh water
on an hourly basis uh based upon full
knowledge of uh
uh the latest weather predictions uh
maybe uh soil and air moisture sensors
and and perhaps even knowledge of what
plants are actually in the garden
to uh and what kind of watering they
need so these types of behaviors are
you know behaviors of devices within a
technosphere that really begin to mimic
the best characteristics of a
sustainable ecosystem
so as the technology becomes more
instrumented more interconnected and
more intelligent
we have the interconnected roles of big
data
and the internet of things helping us
learn how to listen to the data
rather than to the to the hippo the
hippo by the way that's the highest paid
uh person's opinion
yeah
so listening to the data and also
learning you know helping us to learn to
trust
the
real-time optimization of resources that
these smart devices acting in real time
can actually provide for us
so
as the use of big data and the internet
of things becomes more ubiquitous in our
in our lives uh such automation
of uh resource optimization can become
uh
you know sort of a you know background
uh you know that reality for everyone
sustainable living could become the uh
the new default
so the uh the shift you know from a
heavy focus on personal responsibility
to enabling a new default reality
really could be a game-changing
opportunity for us you know mit with its
maker culture is uniquely positioned to
exploit
the
interconnected roles of big data and the
internet of things it can really help
accelerate the emergence of this new
sustainable living ecosystem
so to wrap this up
you know the consumer marketplaces as we
all know has been on fire with
innovation over the the past several
years and successes like the iphone and
the ipad and the android you know these
platforms
you know have have demonstrated the
important role
that needs to be played by user created
applications
and
mit can do a number of things here to
help accelerate this new model by
leveraging platforms and api approach to
these you know platforms where users can
actually start developing apps
some of the things that we can do is
help define the relevant data types and
relationships for strongly
interconnected data these things would
be uh you know time stamps location
things of that nature we can build uh
mashups for blending machine to machine
data
and
behavior data to create
what we might call smart data these
would be such things that involve you
know capturing attitudes choices
interactions activity patterns and we
can enable faculty staff and students
to leverage the smart data to create new
models for pattern recognition
new predicted predictive algorithms for
use in automating relationships between
the uh between their devices and then by
making mit data open for reuse and
redistribution and by enabling uh others
to opt in so collectively
these types of efforts can become the
game-changing key to accelerating the
emergence of a
sustainability ecosystem
within the technosphere
and help us actually scale sustainable
living
so that's what we're trying to help
enable within is t
how can mit be a true force for climate
for leadership and climate change
innovation
so
it's clear we're in an era of
disruptions and that that's happening at
the planetary scale but also here
locally
in boston in the region and that that is
something to be reckoned with both from
the point of view of resilience and how
we prepare for those impacts of climate
change but also
how we think about mit's leadership role
in shifting the conversation around
energy
which is of course happening here both
through scholarship through practice and
engagement and through
teaching um but going for it always is
worth i think taking a step back and
looking at the horizon and asking what
can be done going forward so my work in
washington and at the white house was
focused really around three questions
first
how can we
leverage and import the most exciting
innovations in science and technology to
be deployed for the problem of climate
change so things like big data analytics
and the internet of things and
artificial intelligence that are
transforming other aspects of society
how do we engage and deploy those
technologies to address one of the
biggest challenges that humanity faces
which is climate change and second how
do we innovate the realms of science and
technology themselves to be more
responsive to and create more solutions
to
the energy crisis to the resilience and
preparedness challenges we face around
extreme weather and floods heat waves
droughts etc
and then finally what are the policy
mechanisms how do policies need to
change in order to enable those
innovations to come to the fore
so given that work in that perspective
i see sort of three areas of opportunity
for universities in particular but i
would say mit especially because mit has
been at the forefront of not only
technology and technology innovation of
basic research but also of the
intersection of research and practice
historically
and that is a crucial area where we're
going to need
an incredible amount of activity and
engagement if we intend to to really
face this challenge
so the first opportunity i see is really
in building a marketplace for climate
change risk information so what do i
mean by that we at this moment in time
we have a lot of we have an abundance of
information about how the planet is
changing and how the impacts of that
change are playing out on the regional
basis and to some degree on the local
basis
we know that we are in the short term
seeing extreme weather in 2012 alone in
this country there were about there was
about 110 billion dollars worth of
economic damage as a result of extreme
weather events
we also know that we are seeing
long-term change long-term sea level
rise
but that information is by and large not
being factored in the risk information
into the decisions that people are
making in communities at the citizen
level and in companies so most people
don't buy a house based on even the
information about the historical flood
plain let alone the flood plain going
forward under sea level rise most
companies are looking at
time horizons about one to three years
when they're looking at risks and
they're not really factoring in
near-term risks of climate change some
of that is changing of course
and communities increasingly cities are
very concerned with climate change we
know that boston and cambridge are and
many of you are probably in this room
are familiar with some of the work being
done but cities are
striving or grappling and grasping to
find relevant information how do they
use the national climate assessment or
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change reports to actually
make decisions about infrastructure or
about
social networks or about um how they
think about planning going forward so
there's a gap in that knowledge and
that's a huge opportunity it's it poses
it's an opportunity it's also a serious
challenge for the scientific enterprise
because the scientific enterprise around
climate change has focused on much more
fundamental questions
you know
people don't make decisions based on
average sea surface temperatures on the
other hand that's foundational knowledge
that's critical to understanding the
planetary system
but it it presents a new opportunity to
sort of see how we can contextualize
information for the kinds of decisions
people make and the weather service
provides a good example of how this is
done people look at weather information
based on weather data to make decisions
about whether to harvest and when to
harvest when to make shipments similarly
in the field of medicine we have
clinical practice where people make
decisions amid uncertainty based on
biomedical research but they're able to
make operational decisions in light of
that uncertainty so that's opportunity
one
opportunity two is really around
technologies and innovations at scale
and there are some great comments made
here about ways that
mit is already deploying particular
innovations on campus and demonstrating
those and of course mit has a long
history of commercializing science
commercializing technologies
the range of technologies that are going
to be needed on climate change are
probably well known to a lot of folks in
this room include everything from energy
storage technologies to sensor and
mobile technologies
to renewable energy sources the
deployment of solar at scale
but a university
can do
much more than just commercializing
those technologies it can also
articulate a path
for how those technologies get deployed
and i think this is a challenge and an
opportunity going forward for the
institute to really think about how to
articulate the policies and the
processes that are needed to get those
technologies adopted
and to be
a demonstrable
leader
in making those making the case for how
technologies get deployed at scale
i also think that
this the example of the internet of
things dr charles presentation is a
great example of another role the
institute can play in terms of
technologies and innovations because
there's a real need to
make the connection between how
the technologies that are transforming
other aspects of life or transforming
business sectors
to show how those are relevant to the
problem of climate change and that's a
public good problem you don't
necessarily have a full-fledged market
for doing that yet um in the in and it's
hard for government to be as nimble
enough to demonstrate these technologies
so i think it's a real role for mit to
say we we're going to see we're going to
envision how artificial intelligence and
big data are going to transform climate
change and we're going to make clear
those connection examples we're going to
demonstrate and situ how that's possible
the third opportunity set is around
models for managing change
so as has been mentioned here
climate change is a problem that spans
geographic boundaries it also spans time
horizons
and jurisdictional boundaries
and there's a lot of grappling happening
at the national level at the global
level with how we manage these problems
because sea level rise is not going to
happen even within the context of the
city of cambridge it's happening on a
regional level and we need new
institutions and new approaches for how
we how we address that set of challenges
and increasingly i think there's a need
for a convening function for
universities to bring together the
players from private public sector to
actually make and chart those new
governance structures the northeast and
new england has a great record of doing
this we have the regional greenhouse gas
initiative here which is our regional
cap and trade approach
there are networks national and global
networks of cities coming to the fore
but the challenges are going to be
adaptive they're going to be happening
over time and it's a role that mit i
think can play very strongly going
forward
also i think mit can work very deeply
within its geography and i'm thrilled to
hear about the work that's happening
with the city of cambridge with the city
of boston with the region
because we need models of how different
sectors work together within a sandbox
to address this problem over time
i'll just close by noting three
qualities that mit already has that i
think can aid in the fermentation of its
leadership on to seize these three
opportunities so the first is that
mit has a uniquely long-term perspective
and an ability to harness that
perspective at the institutional level
to make decisions we sometimes take this
for granted because
when we're within a community we
sometimes can't always see its value
relative to other sectors but in the
corporate sector decisions are being
made on the basis of quarterly profits
and sometimes these one to three year
risk horizons in the public sector you
have election cycles and leaders that
are accountable
for the next election but maybe not
looking decades into the future and that
i think is a unique position and
perspective that mit can offer
that
going forward as an institution
to avoid baking in decisions that might
not be that might be expedient over a
10-year horizon but might not be the
best solutions to say reducing emissions
over a 50-year time horizon and we can
talk about what examples of that would
be
the second quality that i think mit has
that it can leverage to this and bring
to the set of um
issues and challenges is its ability to
capture the imagination of people in
terms of how technology gets deployed
a big failure mode um is in sort of the
race regulations that are limiting
science and technology and innovation
deployment on climate change
um is is failure of the imagination the
failure to be able to understand how if
we
made regulatory tweaks if we created the
right incentives we could actually
deploy particular technologies to
transform our approach to climate change
this is an image of the mit media lab
it's from joe paradiso's group
responsive environments group and it
shows
the heat and electricity and human
footprint of this building and it's a
sort of sensor-based internet of things
approach that could be used to be
applied to making energy to making
buildings much more efficient to making
systems more efficient to help with
disaster evacuation and risk but people
have to imagine how that can be applied
and mit has an abundance of researchers
and programs that could be
ways of demonstrating that
finally
mit is a dynamic institution it has
historically
adapted and evolved to challenges and to
meet and to new technologies
the challenge i would pose is that mit
can and should evolve the role of
scientists and of its scholarship and
its campus operations to help develop
what i would call a clinical practice
for climate change and this is the space
that i was talking about that goes
between the basic science of how the
earth system is changing in the climate
climatic disruptions and the practical
operational decisions that companies
need to make in sectors from agriculture
to finance
to
the decisions that communities need to
make cities regions states and nations
and to do this i think it requires um it
does require an evolution to some degree
in the roles that researchers play and
the roles that staff and faculty and
students play to go beyond their
research and to articulate the
ingredients needed at the policy level
for the deployment of technologies and
innovations thank you
i just want to
kick things off a little bit with a with
a reflection that you made jake that it
was good to be good
which i which i think we would all agree
right clearly uh everybody has that uh
has that ambition but i think where the
gulf sometimes exists is of course in
the opera
operationalization of that of that goal
of that ambition and that's something
that i think you guys are facing
vladimir with respect to mit nano which
is a very tangible
uh and you know large element in uh in
mit's kind of you know medium-term
future investment-wise and these
decisions had to be made
i'm kind of curious how
how you've been able to go through this
process
how it has differed perhaps
from
the process
in in its kind of typical sense in the
contemporary paradigm and
your reflections on whether or not in
reality it's much more difficult
to do something different or is it just
kind of a mindset change
i i think actually it's uh you're asking
a fantastic question from perspective of
a building industry that is often uh
very conservative
in adapting the next technology after
all the building needs to stand for next
hundred years
and there are proven methods of building
it that will make sure it operates for
those hundred years in the proper way
you can step back and look at a typical
research lab like mit nano it's really
meant to operate in this modality for
about 30 years
now that allows you a little bit shorter
horizon and a little bit more confidence
although still three decades is a long
time in three decades i say you know
we'll invent anti-gravity we'll have a
whole bunch of physics and science that
will allow us to redesign the lab i mean
that's but the building will stand there
so the ability to actually introduce
entirely new technology uh led us to
quantify tremendously every step of the
way it took about nine months now bear
in mind anything as big as mit nano a
single month of delay is millions of
dollars of extra cost so you have to be
cognizant of where you stand what the
opportunity is
and indeed work extremely hard at
quantifying those opportunities we also
looked at co2 emissions of the building
and ask ourselves very simple question
which is that you know i can do
something today to reduce the co2
emission
but would it be better if i actually
used that money and planted trees in
brazil right or in cambridge area would
that do more co2 reductions
than investing millions and millions and
millions to just do a little bit of
extra co2 emissions so i think weighing
the pros and cons and trying to you know
because there are
another few hundred things we could have
done right at an exorbitant cost
that would have caused us not to build a
building what's what whatever so
you have to do very very careful
analysis of balancing the two and then
be extremely persuasive and use the
mit's ability to say well these are the
numbers we have quantified it there is
no reason why this shouldn't work based
on the physics and science we understand
let's try it out
i guess where i'm going with that
question is
i think the first of is always a big a
big step forward but
you know having gone through this
experience
do you see the opportunity for
not just mit but more broadly when
investment decisions around these types
of facilities are being made that a you
know a planning process that's much more
that's less of an arduous kind of lift
um can be developed but at the same time
capture all the color and opportunity
that exists i i think the lift will
always be arduous in the sense that
we'll always have to spend a lot of time
thinking it's not a simple problem
anytime we introduce a global change
i think what does help tremendously is
to share the experience our goal once
the building is built is to actually
write it up right go ahead and say this
is how it performs we expected this we
got this it's a we should use our campus
as a lab project itself you know us
building one good building is not going
to save the world but us building a
building that others can learn from
might advance the the moment forward
right us building a lot of solar panels
on on the campus is a really good idea
but only if people can see them so that
we can appreciate the value of
technology right and hence be able to
engage in it to develop even better
technology that builds from it
so actually that that's an interesting
useful linkage thank you vladimir um
because i was curious jeremy in your
exercise
so i think you articulated pretty
clearly you know uh you and the group
were passionate about trying to bring
this apparently quite obvious
opportunity to kind of fruition
effectively
and then you kind of stepped into the
complexity of the institution of course
institutions in general and all of the
varying factors that matter
and
you know i'd like to know
one from your perspective how useful
that process was and you think
having more effective communication of
those complexities to to students and
future decision makers
and indeed to people here in this room
who have to kind of manage the place
whilst trying to accommodate these
opportunities
you think we can align and move forward
trying to grasp some of these
opportunities better because of that
process
i certainly hope so and
at so at the outset of our project
it was a class on photovoltaics and so
we wanted to
undergo a project that involved
applying some of the technical
constraints of you know how a solar cell
actually works and integrating that into
a module but also from the
implementation side of what would it
take to actually do this on a campus in
a campus setting in an urban setting
like mit and so
our there were sort of several different
ways we could have gone with the project
um we could have
specked out particular panels from a
specific solar panel insulation company
and
or designed the engine done the
engineering work to analyze the kind of
mounting that would we would need to
make sure that panels on a specific
building could be
you know could withstand high winds and
things like that and we decided not to
do that because what we really wanted to
offer to
the institute and to the office of
sustainability whom we worked with was a
framework for approaching this kind of
problem and demonstrating the kinds of
things that you would need to think
about when undergoing a project like
this
and so we
we looked at
some of the
general design constraints um
there are we looked at the existing
systems that were installed starting in
that have various different mounting
configurations
and so going through and looking at
those systems was really interesting to
us and we learned a lot of things about
okay these are the kinds of issues that
would need to be sorted out we learned
that
the so the installation on the alumni
pool for example
we visited in early december
and it was winter and around half of the
installation was shaded by the sun due
to buildings 16 and 56.
and
first thing you think about when
installing solar panels are well they
need to
they need to be lit with sunlight um and
so that was sort of an obvious thing
that we thought of that
seemed to have been overlooked but it's
just easy to you know when doing that
for the first time
to
not think about what specific day in
december
might cause shading and so going through
that process was really really helpful
and i'm happy to have been able to
contribute to that and deliver report to
the sustainability which
i hope anyone who's interested in
reading
can access in terms of the campus right
you went and you saw this plethora of
roof types that we happen to have
and and then you made a comment about
vladimir putin all these fans on the
roof is there i mean are there simple or
you know simple but
at least sensible steps that can be
taken going forward um for the institute
in terms of its consideration of its
physical plant and design that will
become enabling uh not necessarily let's
do it but make sure that we have a fit
for purpose infrastructure so that these
opportunities can be taken advantage of
if if the economics for example make
sense
right uh and i think that
that is something that is really
important to consider and um sort of as
as was mentioned earlier i think that
piece of it is a little bit of a mindset
shift um
we uh you know camp sustainability is is
something that we're here today talking
about and saying it's really important
but
we also need to integrate that into our
thinking so that it's just second nature
to think oh we're building a new
building on campus how much could we
install solar panels on the roof what
would that look like um and making that
a more and you know that extension not
just solar that extends to building
energy efficiency um green labs all
these kinds of things so i think that
sort of
um really passionately advocating for
these steps um
is and creating that kind of mindset
mind shifts um switch
is is what's really important and i
think that there are sort of a few
reasons
why that's important first
i think it would be important for mit to
take initiative and sort of personal
responsibility and reducing carbon
emissions is one way to do that however
small they may be right um but secondly
demonstration is important and other
institutions can learn how we at mit
handle this issue
and go through all of these really
complex analyses
and that leads into the third thing
which is mit really being a leader for
this
and connecting that aspect of it to all
the other things on campus like learning
about solar
solar energy in class
engaging with research activities going
on on campus and i think that is
how this can really start to build and
disseminate through the rest of campus
and
across across the globe
john
other than your hippo comment which will
stay with me for the rest of my life
one thing that really resonated from
your comments was the
the vision of
big data if you wish the exam
the exhaust of our digital world as a
natural resource
and one of the key uh
key elements to or key characteristics
of a natural resource is that
initially when you start developing them
it's really easy there's huge gains it's
really low cost actually
and yeah later on it gets more difficult
gets more expensive but i think today in
terms of this conversation
we have yet to begin the development of
utilizing what data has to offer in
terms of insight and in terms of helping
to you know shift our thinking and help
helping to identify opportunity and so
on and i'm just curious in terms of the
more kind of
a more operational example have you guys
you know looked around at the
information we have on campus or that we
could easily get our hands on
and then consider how we could use that
in order to kind of you know move us
forward with this kind of sustainability
goal i think most of the data i can't
put a number on it but i would expect
it's it's pretty in pretty much in the
high 90s is dark data
right now it's data that
it's out there but
we don't have any way of getting at it
or looking at it or analyzing it so
there's
the you know it is an untapped resource
you know at this this point but it does
have the potential to fuel innovation
in a way that
we haven't been able to fuel innovation
you know before so it's a pretty
exciting time but it means that for
example on is nt the path forward is not
having a bunch of report writers
that can go write reports against the
data warehouse right we actually have to
have data scientists
you know that can
actually work with these
structured and unstructured data from a
variety of sources
put them together come up with the
learn how to use the tools what tools
are available now but create new tools
for uh for analyzing that data so it's
no longer dark yes so um since you're
since you're actually part of the
administration i'm going to ask maybe a
slightly pointy question but so that's
that's certainly a very interesting
vision
but of course it's all about making
use of that in the operational context
so you know today do you do you believe
that you know we exist within mit in a
rather siloed organizational structure
where for example some of the insights
from within ismt or maybe within
facilities don't cross over effectively
uh that's a question and if if that is
true how do we move to a situation where
we at least disseminate this information
more effectively whenever we're trying
to get to the uh you know
to operationalize this there are there's
some infrastructure work that has to be
done right
so uh job one for us within isn is to
get the platforms in place
get the tool sets in place get the
connectors in place that people can then
tap into
data in in richer richer ways
i think i think
you know just from watching what people
been able to do with mashups involving
map data yes
you know with very simple tools you know
taking a spreadsheet
and then being able to
mash it up with map data geography you
know
the
you know geo-type data
you know is very can be very very
powerful so we just have to take that to
the next level
in terms of dealing with uh data in more
sophisticated ways
um so
ben i'm kind of curious
with your particularly in in dc in in
terms of the thinking that has
surrounded climate change innovation
and making it tangible i'm sure some of
these issues pop up all the time so lots
of good intentions but a challenge in
integrating that for action
so you know can you can you reflect on
what what you guys have seen and how
people are approaching that one of my
charges was to look across we have a 2.5
billion dollar investment in global
research annually our federal government
and if you look across those data assets
it's everything from
satellites like the grace nasa grace
satellites that are taking measurements
of changes in earth's gravitational pull
that tell us about the drawing down of
aquifers like the central aqua valley
aquifer in california right now which
has become very drawn down
to data observational service
data taken
um to experiments uh to epidemiological
data connecting disease and heat
and the question becomes you know how do
you actually
how do you answer questions from these
vast data sources right the potential we
know is great because data analytics is
transforming many aspects of the economy
and it's really the future in terms of
knowledge and information and knowledge
and information i would argue are very
much going to be central to at a minimum
our resilience and preparedness
approaches but probably mitigation too
but so how do you
how do you turn these vast amounts of
data that are in disparate kinds of
formats and different disparate silos
into real intelligence operational
intelligence where you can make
decisions where you could have the city
of chicago
being able to create a map that shows
where its elderly populations are
overlaid with its risk of heat waves
prospectively going forward overlaid
with decisions being made about how
they're going to deal with the built
infrastructure and green space and then
you could make intelligent decisions
based on those data and that's actually
a very simple example compared to the
kinds of things you would hope to be
able to do and need to be able to do
but to actually do that right it
requires an integration across these
different sources from federal data all
the way down to local data from the
scientific data to what's in the
environment so i think the
the issue i think to me it goes back to
this issue of
governance and models for making change
because if you when you have a problem
that complex you're not going to be able
to solve it even with if you had a
hammer as big as the federal government
right you have to take you have to think
about
how you create sandboxes where different
players can come together and are
willing to work together and if you take
that to the institute level here at mit
you know you could create the sandbox of
a particular problem where you need data
to come to bear on that problem and
bring in the resources from different
places work the problem with data
scientists work work it with beautiful
data visualizations like what
folks are doing here at the media lab
and have that be
an example of how you cut through some
of those um i think logistical issues
um that then leads me to you jake i
didn't forget you obviously
um
but as
an experienced uh operator both in terms
of uh
in academia and in teaching and also i
guess in administration across various
roles uh in this area i'm curious as to
you know your reflections on
this challenge of linking the macro
to the micro to the you know to the mit
level demonstrating you know the
usefulness or um
utility of an effort and then scaling
that back up
because as you said
we're in the business of teaching and
ultimately a lot of these uh a lot of
the
the real world experiments the real
world choices that are made here
um through osmosis can hopefully
propagate out and that's one of the big
opportunities we have
um
so you know
let us know what you think i think that
i think of that differently yeah
depending on who you're talking about
right so if you talk about me personally
and my house and my car and stuff that's
one set that's one set of questions
about how
i respond to a global
a global picture when what what i do is
what i do but nobody notices what i do
yes but mit is different
in that there's a demonstration function
here as to what we do and and and um
so
so i think that that
that when when when we take these kinds
of activities
increasing
in fact increasing costs at the margin
in order to achieve some goal which is
outside
nano's research or whatever or heating
the buildings what we're doing and the
question is what we we need to be
thinking
we come
we we
start with what we think the the the the
risk is and what's needed and then the
question what can we contribute to that
beyond just a few
uh a few um
tons of co2 yep and so so it's a
different question it's a different
question here
and so when i think about
what jeremy was talking about
i love it because
again there's this great idea and some
questions where'd that come from oh
students did that
that was a student initiative over and
over that this happens but then the
question if you're going to do
as the way i think of going from the big
problem to the small problem back to the
big problems i think about that question
and and if you if you're going to go the
next step we're going to actually put
money into this then
then what is the question
and it seems to me the question is the
two-part question what what is the cost
to mit at the margin for doing that just
looking at the cost to mit right and is
that cost somehow
related to what what the society
believes is the marginal cost of of of
these kinds of emissions you'll have
that information but that's not the only
information you want you want then you
want to think about
well how would we do this in such a way
that you would have a bigger effect
through through demonstration and here
i'll just quote our work on the on on
the solar business the problem of solar
energy is not
to put
it's not primarily to put
to put modules on roofs right now
we need solar energy at very very large
scale in the very long term and the pro
and and the major challenge with solar
is to bring those is to bring those
costs
the modules and what it takes to install
them and how they integrate into the
system into a point where they can
actually compete
in the system we have uh
hopeful we hope with charges against the
emissions of the fossil fuel sure
so so the question is if you're going to
design that kind of a system what i
would want to
want to see is not only to design where
you find a building and where's a cheap
building to do that but how would we do
that to have the maximum demonstration
outside that's how you get back from the
local to the
back up to the larger problem
um
i think it's you know just reflecting a
little bit more on that i think that's
an example of where the institute has a
goal and jeremy literally put it up
there that's our goal but of course we
all then within the institute have our
own particular job to do and i think at
times there's a disconnect between me
doing my job and me doing my job to the
very best alignment with the institute's
goal and that's a real challenge um so
we have a few minutes for questions if
there are a few thoughtful questions of
course um only
so uh
like mine
better questions than mine please um
thank you so john sturman from the sloan
school so um
very interested in in all of these
comments and i just wanted to offer a
couple of data points on the issues that
have been coming up you know vlad how
much does it really cost using the
numbers uh jeremy your your presentation
as well
so at the new sloan school building
we've been studying for several years
how much it actually cost in additional
upfront capital to
make that building a lead gold
more green building compared to the
standard building we could have bought
there'll be a case study published on
this in the next couple of months but
the bottom line is the net present value
of the uh sustainability initiatives for
that building is 10 million dollars with
essentially no risk off-the-shelf
ready-to-go technologies and the upfront
capital cost delta was
roughly zero and one of the main reasons
for that is if it's more energy
efficient the mechanical systems are
smaller and also
we avoided capital cost for the steam
generation and chilled water capacity
that the building would otherwise have
required
so this is very different than what most
people think
having done formal surveys and informal
surveys about this most people think
when you ask them what would the
additional upfront capital cost be 20
more is the modal answer and the answer
is really about zero and we think the
same opportunities exist for the entire
campus our study of that and there's a
paper on this now available
very conservative assumptions suggest
the npv of an energy efficiency focus
for campus renewal programs that israel
described is 100 million dollars and
that's a very conservative number so
there's a lot of misconceptions out
there
uh about how much does this really cost
and how hard is it it turns out
it's just a lot easier being green than
people think
interested in your comments i am a
tremendous supporter of what sloan
school has done there is a lot of
monitoring of
the brightness of the light throughout
the system there's computational power
that goes there that's minimal compared
to amount of heat that you are indeed
are benefiting from from saving
but you are using variable speed motors
that are not standard in industry and
consequently there is a delta cost
increase in the beginning i do not know
that it's exactly zero
at the end of the day i i think a lot of
what i hear at least from the building
industry is that tremendous amount of
monitoring already exists in nearly
every building that's newly newly built
but only about 10
of the data is truly used in operation
of the building and a lot of it has to
do with the fact that what if you mess
up
i mean if you actually
there is a lack of daring call it or
actually maybe the way of putting it is
if i miscalibrate the building and i
start using a ton of extra electricity
and a ton of extra heat there's cost to
that right
a very large cost so maybe all we need
is
grants uh research grants that would
subsidize the cost of fuel
in a case we mess up right
and if we happen to have a surplus at
the end because we actually have gained
tremendous amount of value from the new
way of operating the building we can
then go ahead and return it back to
whoever gave us the chance to try stuff
out i think one thing we are not doing
is not doing experiments on large scale
because we were a little bit concerned
about what would happen to a building as
a result of us trying things and we need
a backup from someone from some sort of
is it government agency to let us try
these things or is it campus at large to
go ahead and allow us to
experiment with the campus try out and
hence provide the best practice for
others to follow
mit nana will also be lead gold this is
a very interesting example of the
challenge right because the sloan
building tremendous as performance has
been and so on is an entirely different
paradigm to what you guys are challenged
with creating and i think these are
excellent goals and i think we need to
clearly
the
the comparison between you know what we
can achieve with the uh with these
different facilities is something
that's complex and that has to be built
into all of this process one way to do
that calculation i'm not sure if you if
you did or not
is when you do those calculations also
to include a shadow price on carbon
emissions if we did that or not but
that's another way to impose this kind
of thing in internally in in doing in
those doing those calculations the other
point i would make is that there's a
certain level investment that pays off a
lot but you always could do more yes
there's always more to spend and more to
spend and more to spend at higher and
higher costs so it's not as if there's
either a clean building or not a clean
building
there's a there's a if you pardon
the economist there's there's a rising
cost curve for that and the question is
where do you want to be on the cost
curve well i i think you'll that's the
question that's the problem you have
yeah i mean i think your suggestion of
generating uh reports indeed the studies
are the future of the best building
using is it new data analysis or is it
in the new paradigms and how you heat or
cool i mean
technology can do tremendous things and
again we are it's a very large
investment to do an experiment on a
building however uh if we are serious
about making a change without trying
stuff out without trying new
technologies without imagining at least
new technology we won't get there i
think one of the most powerful things uh
energy initiative has done is generated
a series of reports that talk about the
future of coal the future of natural gas
the future natural energy i mean these
are the things that actually spent
people spend time debating what are the
technical opportunities for change and
indeed these reports address the policy
and the social impact as well as
technology that comprehensiveness there
are very few places in the world can do
that mit is one of those places so we
should use it as a resource for the rest
of the world you can also share lessons
about the process so this particular
example of the solar potential work
that's being done here there's a you
know ucla is working with the city of
los angeles to essentially share a
process a mapping tool for
uh evaluating solar potential across the
entire city so once when something's
being done here internally it's not just
the technology you can demonstrate it's
the process for arriving at
you know where you did in terms of when
does the investment become worth it and
obviously there are different
considerations because of the time
horizons which we talked about before
but um i think that's also very valuable
it's the process as you found out of
course that's really uh the critical
path for many of these decisions and
just coming back to your point with
regard to the building so as you know
the builders want to build to code
so this question of well we can do this
this is interesting and very important
but it's really a case of moving the
goal posts for everybody because that's
that's the process that will ultimately
have impact and if we can be a
uh if we can be a a test bed for doing
that then i think that's really very
very exciting
i think we have time for one more
remark or comment we really have the
expertise across the board to deal with
whether it's the policy issues whether
it's how we do the financial uh
cost as well as the technology
and in some ways in the past we've done
this in sort of an informal way where
we've tried to get involved on some of
these particular projects and vlad knows
about we're pushing them on mit nano and
but the so the in some cases it's sort
of disquieting because
um a number of us are doing more work
away from mit whether it's in china or
india or europe on trying to advance
these technologies and what we're doing
here on campus and we really need to
think of a formal way and hopefully with
the office of sustainability we'll be
able to do this now
formal way to try and marshal these
resources so we can do it here on campus
in a better way than we've done in the
past
i think there's lots of things that we
really could accomplish whether it's
from research or classroom exercises or
many consulting kinds of things
where we could move forward in this
thank you leon i think that's actually
an excellent
excellent note to end things on
it's uh from from from what i've heard
this morning
and from
julie's office
it's entirely apparent
the tremendous opportunity we have
and also of course this significant
challenge
in in seizing as much of that
opportunity as possible here on campus
and using that and amplifying that to
have impact more broadly as well in
supporting mit's broader mission um so
let me thank vladimir binna john uh
jeremy and and jake for your uh
fantastic contribution and uh thank you
all for uh for your attention